Я скажу так: ми не планували вижити.
Я не кажу, що ми не хотіли вижити.
Ми не планували вижити.
І якби наказу припинити оборону Маріуполя не було,
я точно скажу, що ні командири, ні я, ні більшість офіцерів
і певно що більшість солдатів не здалися б в полон.
Ми б там загинули.
Або була така ідея, що піти врозсипну
і більшість би загинула, а частина би вийшла.
Рік тому впродовж 86-ти днів бійці гарнізону "Маріуполь"
- а це азовці, морпіхи, прикордонники, поліцейські, тероборонівці та добровольці
- тримали кругову оборону міста у повному оточенні,
з важкими боями та відсутністю будь-якого постачання.
Авіації було просто дуже багато.
Ну, десь ми порахували, половина всієї авіації,
яка працювала по всій Україні,
рівно половина працювала по Маріуполю, а потім по "Азовсталі".
В нас постійно була авіатривога, була загроза масованого авіаційного обстрілу.
Це коли 14 літаків летять за раз.
І коли закінчились просто поверхи, тобто там було,
наприклад, 5 поверхів над бункером, і вони закінчилися,
а авіація працювала, працювала, працювала,
от тоді під кінець в нас були великі втрати від авіації.
Будинки буквально складалися на очах.
Російська авіація обстрілювала Маріуполь та "Азовсталь"
п’ятсот-кілограмовими і двотонними авіабомбами,
постійно працювала артилерія і танки.
Танками вони випалювали все, взагалі, абсолютно.
В мене навіть хлопці підходили, казали,
ну, ми не знаємо, якими снарядами вони працюють,
але танк працює - будівля згорає повністю.
Тобто і тактика використання танків, звичайно,
просто вони заїжджають і знищують повністю будівлю.
Починаючи з верхніх поверхів і отак от складають-складають.
Натомість в українських військових не вистачало абсолютно всього:
людей, боєприпасів, артилерії та навіть їжі.
Те, що зробили солдати в Маріуполі, це надлюдське щось.
Вони адаптувалися до неспинних боїв…
Бої йдуть, там будівля біля будівлі,
далі будівлю знищує авіація, артилерія, танки,
вони переходять в іншу будівлю, і там за день вони могли змінити там 2-3 будівлі.
Це високоповерхівки, дев’ятитиповерхівки.
Потім в них там пів годинки поспати,
ну тому що в нічний час інтенсивність боїв була трішки менша.
А потім вони знов воюють.
І от так протягом 86-ти днів постійно, постійно, постійно.
І, звичайно, ми бачили, як солдати себе відчувають,
як вони воюють, вони стали, знаєте, от такими роботами в голові,
от вони просто, в них була одна задача
- це знищити ворога, вижити, зберегти особовий склад.
Та здаватися ніхто не збирався.
Вони продовжували оборону, хоч ворог намагався їх знищити 24/7.
Тоді весь світ сколихнули фото поранених на "Азовсталі"
- з ампутаціями рук, ніг та важкими ранами.
А в одному з бункерів працював унікальний військовий госпіталь,
де одну з вентиляційних шахт переобладнали під операційну.
У нас функціонально було дві хірургічні бригади,
можна так сказати, ми могли працювати на два столи,
враховуючи кількість хірургів, анестезіологів.
Завдяки хлопцям, медикам, які були на "Азовсталі",
які взяли з собою апаратуру, кисневі концентратори,
були повноцінні два апарати ШВЛ, два слідкуючих монітори,
один з яких дефібрилятор, кисневі концентратори.
Олександр - військовий лікар-анестезіолог.
Він не був у Маріуполі, коли почалося повномасштабне вторгнення.
А на "Азовсталь" потрапив вже 31 березня
- під час спеціальної місії, коли кілька медиків вилетіли з Дніпра
на гелікоптері в оточений Маріуполь.
Хочеш змінювати світ - почни змінювати його з себе.
Через це, чому хтось має це робити?
Тим паче також склалося, що морально був я готовий,
і Маріуполь мені достатньо близький був,
тому що пов'язувалася достатня кількість мого життя, років.
І нам було запропоновано, що буде такий варіант на добровільній основі,
можливість для надання допомоги нашим хлопцям,
нашому шпиталю, який був вже в оточенні в Маріуполі.
Вся територія Азовсталі просто горіла,
як в фільмах про якихось драконів, скажемо так.
Тобто мозок розумів, що відбувається,
а очі - такий дисонанс виникав.
Там, у підземному бункері, команда лікарів проводила важкі хірургічні операції
з повним анестезіологічним супроводом,
серцево-легеневою реанімацією і переливанням крові.
Найбільше, що я пам'ятаю, це ми більше 30 годин не виходили.
Це під час прориву 14-15-го, по-моєму, квітня,
тому що велика кількість була поранених, свіжих.
І от більше 30 годин ми не виходили з операційної,
ну, тому що просто несли, несли, несли.
І це все паралельно під 24 на 7 обстрілом з усього, що можливо,
тому що інколи, коли поряд лягали такі досить серйозні вибухові,
скажімо так, були прильоти, то наш бункер,
це достатньо така велика відносно площа.
І він дійсно, як човен в морі, хитався.
А так, зазвичай, ну, достатньо багато ми зробили.
Оперативних втручань їх, напевно, ніхто не рахував.
Але, ну, я впевнений, що з таких серйозних - це більше 400 таких,
які потребували можливого там якогось, по типу ампутацій,
таких достатньо серйозних хірургічних обробок,
дренування, тому подібне.
Медичні засоби закінчувалися, проте лікарі робили все можливе
для того, щоб врятувати військових у тих умовах.
І робили це до тих пір, поки вище військове керівництво не дало наказ гарнізону Маріуполя
припинити оборону, щоб зберегти життя військового складу.
Початок потрапляння нашого до полону - це 16 травня,
коли ми були евакуйовані.
Потрапили до полону самі тяжкі наші, реанімаційні хворі,
які, ну, дійсно, були дуже критичні.
І якесь уповільнення в їхньому лікуванні - це було, напевно, неминуча їхня смерть.
Тому що, як би, дійсно, медикаменти вже на той час,
на травень місяць закінчувалися, антибіотики, знеболюючі, була знищена апаратура,
не було води, їсти, тобто, ну, як би так.
А потім я особисто виходив 18-го.
Ми б таке рішення взагалі не прийняли,
якби в нас забрали поранених. Це точно.
А от коли ти бачиш, що твій побратим гниє,
лежить там без ноги, в нього там вже пішли ці всі процеси незворотні,
і йому треба медична допомога, тобто він повільно помирає.
І це не так повільно, що годину-дві день, місяць може просто помирати.
Тоді з "Азовсталі" вийшло майже 2,5 тисячі українських військових.
Усі вони потрапили в російський полон, де перебували в жахливих умовах.
Воду привозили нам пожежною машиною,
тобто з якоїсь річки більше всього набирали,
тому що вона дуже тягнула тиною.
Було триразове харчування, дуже швидко прийом їжі відбувався,
вони по секундах засікали.
Дуже довго нас годували спеціально окропом,
тобто він дуже гарячий був, що встиг, скажімо так, то з'їв.
Єдине, що, знову ж таки, катування відбувається.
В основному це током б'ють, голки, ну це стандартно, я не знаю.
І те, що я побачив, і те, що мені не сподобалось, це стосовно татуювань,
це буквально в останніх двох обмінах було, вони змушують або нігтями стирати,
ну, частково так, ранки залишаються.
І от мені сказали, я особисто не бачив, мені сказали,
що одному бійцю залили якесь татуювання окропом
і змусили його стирати теж рукою.
Досі у полоні знаходиться чоловік Ганни,
який приєднався до лав "Азову" після початку повномасштабного вторгнення.
А сама жінка з їхнім тримісячним сином 65 днів провела у бункері "Азовсталі".
Це було дійсно жахливо, і перебування в "Азовсталі"
- це був такий собі виклик долі,
особливо для мене не тільки як для цивільної людини, але і як для мами.
Можна сказати, що це було дійсно таке сталеве материнство.
Ми були в декількох бункерах, останній бункер і основне місце,
в якому ми були, там було 75 людей. 17 з цих людей були дітьми.
Мій малюк був наймолодший не тільки в цьому бункері,
але й взагалі на "Азовсталі".
Обстріли, на жаль, не вщухали майже постійно.
Нас накривали або з кораблів, або з гелікоптерів,
або з літаків, або з "Градів".
У бункері було дуже холодно, не вистачало їжі,
а в самої Ганни від стресу пропало молоко.
Наприклад, для того, щоб робити суміш,
треба було гріти воду на свічці, була саморобна пічка,
але для того, щоб її використовувати, треба було під обстрілами
йти до цієї пічки на вулицю та нагрівати воду.
Ми намагалися зробити якнайкраще, щоб діти не дуже розуміли, що взагалі коїться.
Але, звичайно, діти, які були старші, наприклад, яким вже 10 років,
вони вже розуміли. І я думаю, що в них, звичайно,
будуть якісь симптоми потім посттравматичному розладу.
Вони малювали їжу, тому що, звичайно, була нестача їжі,
їм хотілося чогось солодкого, фруктів.
І ми завжди говорили про те, що вони захочуть їсти
або що вони захочуть купити собі на день народження,
щоб якось полегшити їхнє перебування там.
Взагалі, перебування в бункері - це схоже на такий якийсь жахливий соціальний експеримент.
І в такій ситуації кожна людина стресує,
вона знаходиться на грані життя і смерті.
На поверхню цивільні з дітьми змогли вибратися лише 30 квітня.
Українські військові відвезли їх на маріупольську набережну,
звідки їх забрали представники ООН та Червоного Хреста,
а в автобусах чекали російські військові.
Після цього їх повезли у фільтраційний табір.
Обшукували нас резиновими рукавицями, які не змінювалися взагалі.
Вони намагалися знайти якісь націоналістичні символи.
У мене було татуювання французькою мовою "La vie est belle" - "Життя прекрасне".
І вони думали, що це німецька.
Мені довелося їм доводити, що це не так.
Потім нас допитувала ФСБ, наші покази записували.
Це була доволі тяжка емоційна бесіда,
тому що у фільтраційному таборі вони вже знали, що я дружина азовця.
Де перебуває зараз її чоловік - Ганна не знає.
Росія не виконує Женевські конвенції і не дає змоги рідним зв’язатися з військовополоненими
чи хоча б дізнатися, в якому вони стані.
Тому жінка робить все можливе, щоб світ дізнався про оборонців Маріуполя:
виступає у Конгресі США, ООН та навіть їздила на зустріч до Папи Римського.
Мабуть, останній раз ми бачилися з ним у березні на початку,
а потім, на жаль, він був поранений, і це був останній раз, коли я фізично його бачила.
А далі вже в кінці травня, вибачте, не в кінці травня, а 17 травня,
я побачила відео на одному з пропагандистських каналів,
він виходив на милицях поранений у полон.
Моєму синові зараз півтора року.
На жаль, він не впізнає зараз, тому що він дуже маленький.
Останній раз він бачив свого тата, коли йому було лише три місяці.
Тому він навіть не розуміє, як це взагалі, коли в нього є і тато, і мама.
У російському полоні досі перебуває понад 1900 захисників та захисниць "Азовсталі",
з яких понад 700 - азовці.
Саме вони відтягнули на себе сили росіян
і дали змогу українській армії перегрупуватися
і дочекатися отримання більшої кількості зброї від Заходу.
На той момент, на початок повномасштабного наступу,
я можу точно сказати, що більш підготовленого підрозділу в Україні,
я за свої слова буду відповідати взагалі перед ким завгодно,
більш підготовленого підрозділу в Україні формату полку не було взагалі окрім ОЗСП "Азов",
ну, полку "Азов" на той момент.
І це дало змогу протриматися знову ж таки в оточенні.
Це без їжі, без відпочинку, без душу, ну, там і так далі, взагалі без ніфіга.
І це дало змогу… Це дуже велика частина нашої майбутньої перемоги.
Тому що якби не було оборони Маріуполя, якби не було "Азову" там,
то і не було б оборони Маріуполя - це факт.
Я вам даю слово, це не 99% - це 100%.
Якби "Азову" в Маріуполі не було, оборони Маріуполя не існувало б як такої взагалі.
Маріупольський гарнізон дав змогу втримати інші українські міста.
Саме тому важливо не забувати про їхній без перебільшення героїчний подвиг
і зробити все можливе, щоб кожний полонений повернувся додому.